[Musique]
me
tu veux du café
ou mater officiers
merci
les buts
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
tous les maux denimal
rené lima
voilà
mais
[Musique]
travail durant l'année
et voilà
w
qu'est ce qui se passe avec mon avis
rythme s'est classé secret défense
l'accès au laguiole fiche n'est pas
permis à l'équipage commandes en 16
combats voix commandant chez mon navire
lieutenant je regrette ce sont les
ordres commandant qui a donné six
l'amiral roberts commandant damien alain
où elle commandant d'escadre à bord du
bainbridge commandant bien on va voir se
reposer tous chef de quart expliquez-moi
tout le commandant était furieux qu'on
lui refuse l'accès à son avis il est
allé parler au commandant d'escadron
commandant très bien continuer
[Musique]
attention
ah ah
laissez passer dans les yeux
signez ici commandant merci contre
vous fait irruption sur mon navire comme
on veut savoir ce qui se passe c'est
pour ça que vous m'avez fait revenir du
pacifique commandant nous en avons
discuté hier soir pendant la réunion
vous y êtes john je sais c'est très
grave mais je peux toujours continué à
patrouiller et non je ne peux rien faire
je ne peux pas l'empêcher de prendre mon
avis tu veux l'armée m'a déjà pris ma
vie ma famille quoi elle fume on a
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça va changer
toute façon je vais faire remonter sa en
haut lieu et vous verrez que quelqu'un
écoutera si vous en toucher deux mots à
quiconque
la seule chose que vous aller commander
ce seront des ranchers des pelles et des
pioches dans un pénitencier accepter la
promotion dont dieu et fermez là une
fois pour toutes là je la vois soyez
sympa dit amen à tout fait qu'on vous
demande
oui chef volontiers pendant que j'aurai
le cul vissé sur une chaise de bureau
avec mon avenir pour ira dans le port
qu'est-ce que ça va changer de toute
façon surtout pour la marine
autant mettre au placard tout de suite
qu'est ce que vous voulez mettre au
placard repos messieurs caméra nous
étions juste en train de râler je tenais
à dire que je sais que c'est difficile
et que ça semble être la fin du monde et
ça l'est amira je désire ou plutôt chez
exige d'avoir une seconde chance
accordée la moye commandes à oublier ce
satané navire ainsi vous pourrez passer
plus de temps en famille ma femme vient
de me quitter
écoutez on vous offre une promotion dans
une école de formation vous forgerez la
nouvelle génération de sous mariniers
ouailles anthony c'est d'accord c'est
d'accord
à ne plus vendre des bibans h les
membres n'élit pas la permission
débutera à 20 heures
je répète la permission des ménages
comment dans le bâtiment est prêt
le bâtiment est prêt très bien son
travail messieurs
nous avons toutes les fautes oui et j'ai
terminé transmettez les au renseignement
naval immédiatement très bon travail
continue
maintenant éteignez tous à vos autres
mais l'écouté
[Musique]
un capitaine doit couler avec son navire
mon
tu perds ton temps sur ces âneries avec
ton espèce de quota farfelue la phase 1
de fantômes n est pas un chasseur de
fantômes farfelues ce n'est pas contre a
bien sûr que si ce n'est pas toi de le
faire si c'est à moi puisque c'est ce
que j'en sais la marine américaine n'a
jamais ils l'ont tenu secret 70 ans
la marine américaine n'a jamais effectué
de recherche paranormales dans les
années 40 sous marin fantômes que tu
cherches n'existe pas je reçois tous les
jours des plaintes du ministère de la
défense ou de l'état major de la marine
à ton sujet tu crois vraiment que la
marine menaient des recherches
paranormales dans les années 40
tu les bombarde avec des demandes
ridicule d'informations ici comme ça que
tu sais tu ça parce que j'ai demandé
d'accord
laisse tomber concentre toi sur ce que
tu sais faire mais mais mais c'est notre
droit et mon droit d'avoir accès aux
informations qui porte sur mon grand
père regarde regarde ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas d'une simple chasse aux
fantômes dont je te peter dille petter
des étudiants sont venus se plaindre ils
disent que tu empeste l'alcool quand tu
arrives en cours et là je vois que tu as
une bouteille sur ton bureau à quoi tu
joues bon sens qui m'a offert cette
[ __ ] de bouteilles tuer les
anniversaires peter ne gâche pas tout à
cause de ça tu va ruiner ta belle
réputation pour ses bêtises
d'accord c'est ça ou ton post
rien que ça ben tu sais quoi
que me dirais tu si je te rendait la
tâche bien plus facile simplement te
disant que tu a démissionné c'est comme
ça que tu veux finir ta carrière alors
vas-y tu peux te mettre c'est un
bouteille de bon rhum dans le cul selon
farid mais santé je te souhaite une
bonne journée veggie pride watts
je m'appelle george clooney je faisais
partie technique d'ingénieur du son par
ailleurs riche en 1943 j'ai commencé
dans la salle des machines
puis j'ai des ghettos ça me plaisait
d'être guetteur parce que quand on est
un guetteur sortait sur la passerelle et
en prenez leurs revenus dit qu'ils
étaient postés dans le kiosque
descendait pour son petit déjeuner et en
prenait sa place
si ensuite je lai dans la salle des
machines je pouvais y entrer sans rire
que lui est il arrivé où était-il passé
toutes ces années pourquoi était-il là
aujourd'hui
c'est pas je n'arrive pas à savoir ce
qui s'est passé il ya 70 ans j'ai appelé
kobalt mais personne ne s'est remis hier
personne ne connaît la réponse
lisa qui vous rappellent un message
donc je ne sais pas ce qu on nous a
caché caché tous
prix
il leur est arrivé la même chose où
était-il passé toutes ces années
vous êtes est il aujourd'hui
je n'arrive pas à savoir ce qui s'est
passé il ya 70 ans
j'ai appelé pas mal mais personne ne
sait rien certains rappellent qu'il faut
foutez le camp
juppé dit foot le corps qu'est ce que tu
veux est-ce que ça va j'arrive pas à
croire que vous ayez démissionner vous
aller décrocher non c'est vrai oui oui
vous aller décrocher ou oui mais c'est
bien vrai je ne vais pas décrocher
résidence de peter william s'écoute
quittez pas je le passe c'est pour vous
ouais
oui exact je suis le professeur williams
quoi qui êtes-vous
vous savez quoi j'ai un message pour
vous un way allez vous faire [ __ ]
ouais qui s'étalait
il ne répond pas les semaines vous allez
répondre un tu as perdu la tête c'est
pas vrai a démissionné à l'eau excuse
moi je n'ai pas fait de visite
il vous dit pas comme en voit tellement
ce live en deux mois recommencez quoi il
écoute moi bien si c'est une
plaisanterie de mauvais goût alors je
vais t'arracher la tête
quoi
attendez et comment vous savez ça oui
bien sûr
demain
le 13 de ce mois
c'est pas vrai non bien sûr bien sûr
main
1 bien sûr bien sûr
voila voila quoi plus dans merde merde
shay pas y croire j'ai réussi vous
arrivez pas quand on a accès online fish
qui nous laisse 24 heures soit un jour
pour faire des recherches à bord c'est
pas vrai vous vous fichez moi j'aurai
besoin de tout mon équipe je veux que tu
viennes aussi je louperai ça pour rien
au monde
t'es sérieux là toi aussi tu viens on va
enfin savoir ce qui est arrivé à mon
grand père tu as quoi tu veux pas le
savoir
non non je veux pas le savoir on a
divorcé à cause de sa petite heure ouais
j'en ai rien à faire pascontent
entamèrent complètement gâteux et wac
est convaincu que le monde entier tourne
autour de ton grand père tu penses
vraiment que j'ai envie de recommencer
les de revenir en arrière
tu es là depuis le début
toi et moi tous les deux à éplucher
toutes ses archives
j'ai besoin de toi j'ai besoin que tu
m'aides à traiter toutes ces
informations on a coeur 24 heures un
jour je n'ai pas droit à l'erreur alors
steffi
je ne peux pas y arriver sans ton aide
oh merde il faut que j'appelle mike mike
weightman quoique non non non non non
non non non non pas lui non
[Musique]
tenez c'est pour vous
700 livres vous êtes dingues ou quoi et
700 livres ton fantôme va me coûter 700
livres des fois on les trouve des fois
on les trouve pas ici pour lire vous
savez c'est comme ça va passer trois
jours à fouiner autour de chez moi et
vous êtes pire ailleurs
je vais vous en donnez moi des 700
livres
[Musique]
mike salutaire ouais non je vais bien
tout couac et le bruit ah non aya pack
wii bien gbagbo
[Musique]
qui part
non c'est plutôt tranquille ces temps ci
quand on va bien sûr
sans problème
[Musique]
écoute voilà ce que j'écris
je prends deux premiers avions demain
matin
oui moi aussi je trouve ça super
excitant
bon sujet
[Musique]
hu
eh ben c'est toujours dans l'enfer pour
trouver votre maison j'y mets pas
m'échapper comme ans qu'il est là dans
mes bras ça les contempteurs bol de voir
mon paternel comment ça va enfin betty
donc tu t'es mis au score regardez le
sont plus alors qu'est ce qui se passe
en faire un peu ton pays qui part faire
puisque hopping sur lui et c'est
celle-là jan fischer quand tu m'as dit
ça c'est incroyable non on voit que les
premiers à poser le pied sur ce navire
depuis le jour où cet événement s'est
produit si crois toi tu arrives à y
croire non pas vraiment non elle salue
c'était ça lui mike seulement ça va ça
content de m'avoir elle est en forme je
m'y attendais pas du tout hier alors que
j'étais assis tranquillement dans le
salon un type du ministère de la défense
m'a appelé ouais certains garmin
j'aime bien ce qui s'est passé et ce qui
a changé pourquoi maintenant un garmin
ouais ouais ce que je comprends pas
c'est pourquoi ils t'ont donné accès à
un sous marin qui a été classé secret
défense aussi longtemps tu sais quoi ça
me dépasse
mais je suis preneur tu vois ouais cbi
qui sévit kiwi salut ville qui regardent
dynamique et tu sais ce qu'on aurait dû
faire
on aurait dû faire venir les types de
l'émission sur le paranormal
pourquoi on aurait besoin d'eux puisque
tu es là oui c'est ça nike et le blanc
anormal je vois déjà l'affiché sinon
c'est plutôt vendeur nous sommes plein à
une paranormal
on y va tout le monde c'est bon stacy
allez on y va
allez les filles voilà voilà où est ici
dépêche-toi
[Musique]
lassouts
et voilà les enfants c'est parti souris
n'est pas contente
garmin
faites-les passé
vous pouvez ouvrir
ils sont là
excellent il y à clé williams avec trois
autres et écouter ça
l'une d'eux et son ex femme vous avez
compris les ormes oui et les règles
d'engagement
c'est compris parfait
regardez ça regardez ce bateau ou à
regarder ce professeur williams nous
sommes venus effectuer des recherches
sur lui et c'est cela oui nous vous
attendions je lis bateau c'est un navire
les sous marins sur des navires et
pourquoi on les appelle pas des bateaux
la marine considère tous les bâtiments
comme des navires même si autrefois les
sous-marins été lancée par des
remorqueurs tu le savais bonhomme ya que
deux types de navires dans ce bas monde
a les sous marins et les cibles vous
vouliez l'accès
vous l'avez
est assez sympa
elle en prendre les 5
ça va aller
mag maurice et son équipe par la normale
sont en train d'embarquer sur le ss
dyotte fiche
tu peux lui dire de la fermer attendez
je suis sûr que ce navire et tenter des
trucs pas anormaux de dingue
allez c'est parti
allez mon masseur un peu plus d'accord
passe moi mon sac tu veux merci bon je
vais descendre à givet
ça y est j'y suis
[Musique]
[ __ ] garmin
je suppose qu'on prend les sacs
[Musique]
malade j'ai une grand mère
c'était quoi
[Musique]
quelle horreur
ça fait combien de temps qu'il est mort
il m'a foutu une de ces trouille votre
grand père comment savez vous que le
commandant sterling était censé prendre
les commandes de la lionne fiche il a
disparu un peu plus tard dans la journée
mais ça ce n'était qu'une supposition
jusqu'à présent
j'allais demander si ça allait mais je
vois que tout va très bien
j'ai pas besoin aux affaires je veux un
verre d'accord très bien t'as pas besoin
d'un verre mais t'as pas besoin de moi
ici non plus
écoutez je suis désolé de m'être énervé
mais je suis tellement en colère et
bouleversé la toutes ces années de
recherche
toutes ces années d'investigations au
sujet de mon stade et grand-père de ce
qui lui était arrivé et voilà qu'il
s'est tué on à faire un [ __ ] de
susciter c'est un véritable gâchis
[Musique]
dia même pensée humaine gêne
mike batt moi ma tablette elle est dans
le sac
je ne lui fait pas confiance vous savez
il nous cache quelque chose qui ça mike
quoi inonder s'il tue donc alors je me
contrefous de ce que fait monsieur
carmine tant que monsieur qu'hermine
n'interfère pas dans mes recherches
monsieur garmin peut faire tout ce que
bon lui semble
on ne ferait pas appeler quelqu'un
pourtant grand père du personnel médical
peut-être je pense pas qu'il aille très
loin
c'est pas le moment
qu'est ce qui lui prend il n'a peut-être
pas tes blagues de mauvais goût
oui c'est moi williams et son équipe
sont en place et vous savez quoi
le commandant staline n'a jamais quitté
son navire ça a l'air d'un suicide
il y à une lettre non c'est moi qui
l'ait non je crois pas que ce soit un
problème non tout se passe comme vous
l'êtes est prévue
je dois vous laisser mg de la visite
non
ça devrait vous intéresser
vendredi un vendredi 13 génial la marine
la bla bla le 'lion' fille sera
transformé en navire d'entraînement pour
les opérations de commandement de
l'atlantique sera ré équiper affecté la
veille son capitaine a été affecté la
veille
quoi mais je croyais que tu avais dit
qu'il était en cale sèche les quais mais
ces documents ça vient du même
lieutenant-commandant même date
mais le contenu différent chez moi
les premiers pas vers la vérité à propos
du lie depuis chez sérieux là à temps on
est d'abord ya un cadavre est une
histoire de dingue
si tu lui dis oh on pourrait faire une
photo les kiwis c'est une excellente
idée
on peut faire une photo je la mettrais
sur mon site mike morris expert en
investigation pas anormal tu n'as mettra
pas suite foot
si vous voulez bien ça va ça va allons-y
phr non là on en finisse
souriez oh vous voulez bien
c'est bon
ça y est
dites light biche bizarre
[Musique]
et qu'est ce que tu fais ça s'ouvre pas
qu'est ce qu'il ya j'ai vu ça va pas
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est jeanne voir
un truc inquiète c'était sûrement un
courant d'air qui a traversé sous marin
d'accord et voilà mal et vient relève
toi tu regardes tu as vu ça c'est ouvert
non non pieters et s était sûrement un
truc paranormal béquille c'est bon là un
un courant d'air ne fait pas claquer une
porte de 200 kilos et j'ai vu quelque
chose
michael et revient année quoi la porte
s'est ouverte ya pas mort d'homme
et c'est d'ouvrir deux secondes mais il
coûtait faut arrêter un peu il faut
qu'on se concentre toi ne provoque les
mecs
génial vraiment génial aller sur twitter
je vais essayer qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe ce truc est
coincé border ça s'ouvre par banque
calme toi ou qui sortent déjà descendu à
les calmer c'est rien du tout elle va
s'ouvrir comme l'espace il faut juste
forcer un peu c'est tout c'est un peu
serré je ne sens pas d'accord ok ça se
voit pas super seven faut qu'on trouve
carayol s'en tape amicale et après
trouver une autre issue que j'y arrive
pas les écrous sont trop celle ci est
vraiment pour mac est en toi c'est pas
aussi grave que ça il ya un peu
claustrophobe
il est un peu claustrophobe génial
m
à temps
marek malik set c'était qu'outil et
cadenassé de l'extérieur tu viens tu te
souviens il ya un cadenas à les dessins
crise même si tu t'appelais contre les
parois avec une clé ou un truc du genre
qu'on retient une attention personne de
t'entendre est si grave
pas si grave passe est grave pour toi
peut-être mais moi je raffole pas d'être
enfermé dans des des petits espaces sans
parler des petites structures en métal
conçu pour aller sous l'eau que je
trouve un moyen d'attirer l'attention
vous entendre quoi il dit que personne
ne l'attend en redescend pourquoi parce
qu'il n'y a personne autour du sous
marin ce soir il ne vous reste plus qu'à
attendre demain matin 10 qui regarde ton
téléphone on va être un moment d'accord
il faudra faire avec
vous pouvez rester là si vous voulez
mais faudra attendre de toute façon
super
vous l'entendez nu peter ça vient d'où
ça vient de l'arrière
[Musique]
ça vient de là
juste là et merde
des fantômes vous voyez je savais dès
sérieux la super mamie sur un avion ça
ouais c'est super on est sur un vieux
rafiot de 70 ans qui se coule tout seul
c'est génial il ya toujours une
explication rationnelle make way c'est
sur yoni tu vois pieters acheter ma vie
dit d'accord doit nous faire chez moi
que tu descendras celle des machines
seulement trop voir ce qui s'y passe tu
peux le faire pour moi d'accord j'y vais
et toi vie qui tu surveilles mike jeter
si tu le fais mais ça on a déjà essayé
mais ça pas vraiment marché
comment ça se fait que vous êtes aussi
sûr de vous
vous allez nous aidez moi non
vous êtes un gros coup
[Musique]
je comprends vraiment pas là je sais pas
mats ek a peut-être raison sur ce coup
là
quoi ce bordel
ça bouge tout s'est tu vois ce que je
vois
tout ça je peux pas loin
c'était pas y croit salut tout le monde
mike tu as touché aux commandes de ce
navire non on n'a rien touché mais tout
s'est mis en marche tout seul dans le
bateau navire exact ne l'énervé pas plus
attendre je commence à denner ont pas
c'est alan tas de ferraille au fond de
l'eau c'est pas du tout vivant de quoi
tu parles
oh
d'accord explique nous sommes et c'est
de l'étamât ben c'est intéressant
c'est quoi ce truc fait pareil pour tous
dites moi vous le voyez aussi quoi ça
n'a rien du tout moi non plus je vois
rien du tout mais mais vous
génial est maintenant d'accord là ça y
est je commence à flipper
la vache vous avez senti ça ouais très
bien j'ai l'impression qu'il se
préparait à marcher je retourne en salle
des machines
ma très bonne idée
m
mais
[Musique]
ricardo un coupe circuit il faut qu'on
trouve un moyen de couper les moteurs
je vais à l'arrière
j'étais prêt à démarrer
faux
dans ce poste de central
j'ai avec moi un désir
piqué
et pourtant
turenne
vous allez rester planté là sans vous et
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passerait
peut-être navire
avec quelque chose et vouloir casser car
n'y paraît
mais ne pensez pas ta main comme ça
vous allez lui répondre à quoi joue
exactement du calme pour avait invité
sur ce n'est qu'un bébé shenzhen est là
bas ne me dira est énorme journée
carbine comme osgood arrête ce moteur à
essence ou diesel
toutefois les attentions
[Musique]
m
j'en trouvais sympa oui c'est quoi je
vais préparer moi même d'accord
[ __ ]
merci
[Musique]
taissy
on n'est pas tout seul dans ce cas
[Musique]
ok
alors voyons ça
qu'est ce qui se passait
[Musique]
aux parents qui quoi qu'il arrive on n'y
peut rien on est coincé tiens regarde
et merde
[Musique]
rien nouveau [ __ ]
je vais aller vérifier les tracés
[Musique]
d'après ce que je vois on est au large
des côtes de la nouvelle angleterre dans
les lumières ne croise pas les lumières
correspondante
berne
garneau bourdelas coûte quoi elle a
raison
j'arrive pas à faire marcher quoi que ce
soit quoi j'ai raté quelque chose tu as
raison l'écho a tout faux
où sont tous les ponts oui la centrale
c'est quoi ce truc qui vous est ce que
west on a une petite heure comment tu le
chose ça c'est bon j'en peux plus là ce
qui se passe n'a vraiment aucun sens
ce n'est pas vous mais quand
en fait
je crois qu'on est le 13 août 1943
au matin
on s'arrête mais oui on s'arrête j'ai
sortir j'ai sortir de là bye bye my ne
remontent pas mike
mike
ouvre l'écouté mais
m
elle est verrouillée
mais veulent écouter yann et peter peter
pour les regarde
ouvrez les coutures il y purge des
ballasts sont en train de s'ouvrir
jamais dire pour plonger bike ou voix
l'écouté
iter cabine vous pouvez venir venez
désolé je ne peux pas me taire
comment ça vous ne pouvez pas évident
vous venez bédéiste au vu d'un regard
buteur
quoi
les ballasts teinture
[Musique]
tenez vous bien tenez vous
faux
[Musique]
la fermeture qu'ils écoutent ils doivent
sûrement faire partie du protocole
d'objets du moulin
c'est ce que j'espère
dix mètres continue
12 m
17 m
18 m
j'apprends vraiment à détester les
sources
non
tout va bien
rien de cassé
et maintenant il va vous suis là
l'écoutille l'écoutille 7 ouverte d'un
coup qu'est-ce qui se passe
piqué et ensuite quand elle s'est
ouverte cet engin a changé d'avis
comment il peut changer d'avis c'est
qu'un bateau [ __ ]
ça suffit garmin vous allez parler vous
allez nous expliquer ce qui se passe il
nous faut des réponses je peux pas vous
les connaissez pas le droit d'en parler
ou ne veux pas trop en parler
qu'est ce que vous foutez sur ce navire
si vous n'avez pas le droit d'en parler
alors vous écoutez écoutez je ne suis
pas autorisé à embarquer ce qui a raison
et que nous tentons ça il n'est pas
autorisé à en parler ou à vous êtes
autorisé ne les y parle je vous demande
de vous ok je n'ai pas le droit d'en
fiscaux allez vous enfin vous avez pas
m'atteindre
mais qu'est ce que vous faites non en
fait ça les arbitres mais n'a qu'à les
renvoyer et il s'en passe pas grande
chose que vous ignorez chez moi c'est
moi qu'est-ce qu'on fait madame qu'est
ce qu'on fait madame ce navire a
vraiment équipe et nous réserve
[Musique]
pourquoi t'as fait ça pour sauver le
connais tu le connais tu pouvais même
plus respect doit plus rester avec lui
et maintenant tu es bon la tuerie un peu
tirés de toi si tu avais fais quoi tu es
devenu complètement dingue ça va pâtir
non mais t'es taxes et pour ça je vais
plus marié de tous elle sera en partie
pour ça c'est pas vrai mais qu'est ce
que tu as fait qu'est ce que tu as fait
ton temps tu es sauver la villa bonheur
calme toi là quand jessica la cession
d'icade regarde regarde moi la ccir
[ __ ] vous croyez pas qu'on en a sept
problèmes comme ça sans que pour facile
ce soir montre est bien celle ci par
fouillent les sacs de guerre mise
d'accord j'ai bien dit il faudra bien
trouver quelque chose pour la bassée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tu vas me dire
ce qu'ils ont essayé de savoir une fois
pour toutes ce qui se passait on va
demander quelque chose
tiens
qu'est ce que c'est il est bizarre ce
mec
big boi on a trouvé ça et du matériel
audio et vidéo mainate bon vient de
régler un problème mais il nous en reste
un [ __ ] pourquoi tu me regardent comme
ça tu penses que c'est ma faute c'est
toi qui nous a amenés ici c'est pour ça
qu'on est là ouais ouais vous écoulé un
flingue sur la tempe pour vous forcer à
venir
ouais ben vous savez quoi on va arriver
ça tout de suite d'accord c'est ma faute
d'accord très bien allez on passe à
autre chose
ce
[Musique]
pourquoi vous allez me détacher pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi tout ça
expliquez-moi pourquoi
dites moi pourquoi pourquoi tout ça
c'est une longue histoire d'accord
attendez attendez ps n'ait lieu bas les
pattes en faites pas avoir parfaitement
voir cette faute hors aller laquelle
celle là pourquoi quel [ __ ]
quoi vous ne savez pas tout
vous allez me détacher
vous allez me dire ce qui se passait
allez vous faire [ __ ] là
rester là vous êtes punis
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne m'ont rien dit
[Musique]
tekken
je
[Musique]
mille euros
dgo
à la station
m
[Musique]
on veut pas
grégoire
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es descendu dans ta cabine
de faire sauter la cervelle
barrette
oui comme ça tu sais quoi
je t'ai trouvé ma [ __ ] merde j'aurais
dû écouter mon ex femme
c'est elle qui avait raison c'est vrai
des bas il était temps que tu reconnais
ce que j'avais raison
mais non
[Musique]
et oui oh oui
mon grand père est pas là pour l'instant
tu sais on né en 1943 il doit être pas
là on a besoin de toi
un petit dernier en l'honneur de cadres
tu sais je me suis toujours demandé si
tu avais raison
et on dirait qu'on est sur le point de
savoir
c'est ce que je pense et on peut savoir
à quoi tu penses
le monde centrale
vite y aller dépêche-toi rennais leader
qu'est ce que je fais avec plaisir allez
on s'est compris
allez fait si bien
suis moi
voyons ce qui se passe
bien
[Musique]
art
wright
triste
j'étais sous marins allemands
ce thème path à dornach peter on ne
torpille quand ils nous auront coulé une
chanson contre x pour qu'on fasse
quelque chose
il ya des milliers de soldats ses
carreaux de ravitaillement
professeur laissez-moi vous aider fermez
la garmin
we might descendre voir comment ma gamme
idée car j'y vais tout de suite
[Musique]
keller à castillon se faire
tu vois ces chiffres je veux qu les
relais familial
[Musique]
ok attend
i wanna hold up et chercher du papier
n'avait pas de papiers on venait fois
écrite
écrire un parfait
maintenant 0 degré photo
et attend maintenant de 1400 d'être en
même temps 20 ce coup là sur 2400 m
jacques pas dire que j'ai vu c'est quoi
si les mains moites ses environs plus
d'armes il y encore en approche 7 12
noeuds trop ça tombe trop tard quand un
an faute ce taux quand approche et tout
ce qu'on approche à tous non ça veut
dire qu'on doit faire jupiters croix
gammée quoi quoi regarde le chemin
le sous marin est complet nous aider
mais si ça dit qu'il est en attente ça
veut dire que des merdes les tubes sont
vides
il faut que j'ai chargé une partie j'ai
bien entendu nous faut que tu ailles
charger une torpille ecoute-moi écoute
moi tu restes là tu me préviendra qu'on
avira une solution tirer classique
frappe verrouillé moi je vais essayer de
le trouver comment on charge une
torpille tué merde très bien d'accord
dubaï
papa est rien
[Musique]
contactés les taux moyens
ben toi du méchouar aînés
[Musique]
vif au concierge de ses torpilles
dans un véhicule d'accord attends tu
veux les faire rentrer là dedans d'un
cadeau dont une toile il ya des milliers
de boutons et valve mec tout ce qu'on a
à faire cette charge et au repli dans un
tube d'accord ensuite le navire
stacy et c'est de voir si tu trouves un
manuel sur le lancement des torpilles
quelque part qu'il te plaît
tu m'en occupe peter g j'ai bien dans la
marine on a besoin de son aide
d'accord pour toi
par contre
il faut qu'on mette ses partisans du oui
c'est raisonnable est ce que vous serez
raisonnable mais pas celle d'un accord
d'accord dépêchez-vous années sarah lévy
des mots
t5 en dame
[Musique]
carbine qu'est ce que vous foutez
dépêchez vous
81 l'attend
[Musique]
quid en ratatinant l'enseignante bon
alors il faut digérer sur cette poignée
poussée se lever vers le haut d'accord
et enfin ce bouton la folle tournée
d'accord paris peter
s'occuper arriver il faut qu'on ouvre
cette rapide accord ne tournait pas
c'est pas nivelles avant d'avoir ouvert
la vanne d'évacuation d'accord par merde
c'est pas là c'est pas grave on se
dépêche aller pour faire vite il faut
qu'on cherche est au pire alors vous
prenez simple accroché de là à les
faucons déplacer quand dépêchez vous
si bon chemin ok allez tous bien voir se
retirer
mais pas trop tard
allez
nicolet au caire
on est concerné
non à l'ipv6
j'ai passé
et
tagetik qu'est la même chose il faut
console secteur
sa vie fut volé des tâches et rochers
donnez moi ça
ouais super u
tom laporte mack allait presque
courageuse et le second par la lancée
tapie n'a approche torpille on approche
est terminée
c'est bon le tube deux tubes le canada
350 m
tapie toujours en approche
qu'est ce qui se passe t'il du job
c'est pareil pour abattre cette affaire
le marquage ce côté-là côté de l'artère
m
l'explosion s'est rodé
il aurait sûrement il entre sur l'eau
mais 38 morts c'est pas un cargo dans la
vie tellement cargos gros bataillons
[Musique]
george w
on a bien joué monsieur j'imagine que ça
fait de nous et du navire des héros
après on approche smalling ou bien tout
le monde
[Musique]
tu sais quoi ce bordel il va bien ça
pique et oui je vais bien on a échappé
belle
carmine
pourquoi suis je crois que c'était pas
censé se passer comme ça qu'est ce qui
n'était pas censé se passer quand tous
éteints ça c'est un pourquoi est ce que
tous et à merde voilà une autre s'est
passé
l'album chercher là dedans tu vois là
bas bon là ouais
mais c'est pas vrai
attentif on est vraiment dans la merde
35 m
on peut descendre jusqu où comme
jusqu'au fond si on n'arrête pas
[Musique]
quarante mètres
javaux
[Musique]
je
c'est un cauchemar
[Musique]
ok
rien n'y a pas de blessé est-ce que ça
va dit vick et vicky vie future
vital et norbert non
[Musique]
non
[ __ ] béate
on a fait tout ce qu'on devait faire
alors pourquoi petter pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant pourquoi
on est toujours dans ce tas de ferraille
oui garmin pourquoi on est toujours là 1
pourquoi on est là on est là à cause de
ta [ __ ] de position mike regarde moi
le voilà le résultat theater
dans toute sa splendeur avec quelques
liens tu veux mourir pour son grand père
puisse rayonner dans la gloire devenir
un héros qu'on soit tous des héros bah
tu sais quoi moi je veux sortir de ce
rafiot de mahler avant de mourir et
c'est tout
garmin vous pouvez me donner un coup de
main s'il vous plaît faut qu on la
déplace doucement et vous pouvez me dit
[ __ ] va te faire [ __ ]
peter c'est pas ta il a raison
c'est ma faute
c'est ma faute si vous êtes là
[ __ ] qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
[Musique]
et
on s'éloigne encore
il ya forcément quelque chose là dedans
qui nous indiquera ce qu'on doit faire
alors trouvé le trouver là allez vous
faire [ __ ] vous le savez alors
dites-nous écoutez moi bien
le ministère de la défense a besoin de
ma présence ici
alors ça suffit avec vos questions peter
n'avez pas le droit de monter à bord
avant ce soir
vous le saviez
vous saviez que tous allaient se
produire et vous nous avez rien dit je
ne pouvais pas je suivais des orgues
lutens vous et vos ordres
[ __ ] vous auriez plus au moins nous
prévenir je n'avais pas le droit
d'interférer d'accord ça aurait pu
changer le dénommé ardi nous vous n'avez
que ce mot à la bouche
un [ __ ]
tout ce qu'il entend par des loups -
j'en sais rien du tout mais je vais le
découvrir
[Musique]
un sous marin c'est pas le meilleur
endroit pour garder un secret
très bien
vous voulez des réponses vous allez en
avoir d'accord voilà j'ai reçu l'ordre
d'observer de documenter et de rapporter
et de ne pas interférer oui oui jusque
là je crois que j'ai compris votre plan
observé documentaire apporter nos pas
interférer et il n'y a rien d'autre dans
votre plan gouvernemental
une fois qu'on sera dense il fallait que
je sois là d'accord je ne savais rien
aussi mais ils ne m'ont rien dit ça
craint d'être en bout de chaîne pas vrai
vous êtes contente ça craint oui mais je
sais que c'était nécessaire
d'accord si j'avais su que j'étais censé
rester là tout le temps alors j'aurais
pu j'aurais pu faire quelque chose ou ne
rien faire du tout et de toute façon
mieux vaut laisser les choses se
déroulaient d'elle-même
ainsi le cours de l'histoire ne change
pas là c'est une situation très critique
qu'est ce qu'elle est si critique
réfléchissez l'équipage du yacht fiche
était censé embarquer demain
c'est nous l'équipage du laguiole fiche
en 1943 on ne connaît pas tous les
détails
tout ce qu'on sait c'est que c'est
arrivé et quel a été le des noirs c'est
trop tard vous nous avez déjà aidé vous
avez déjà changé les règles vous avez
changé l'histoire
vous vous foutez de moi
c'est pour ça qu'on est là
eh ben je regrette mais je vais pas
rester les bras croisés en attendant
qu'on crève tous ici je vais pas laisser
le destin décider de notre sort sur par
yapi non non non non pas question par
question ne faut pas qu'il s'agit mais
faut qu'on soit sûr qu'ils fassent
exactement tout ce qu'il a fait la
première fois que c'est arrivé
écoutez c'est très grave d'accord pepper
ne doit pas être au courant de quoi que
ce soit on doit partir des principes que
tout ce qui est arrivé est arrivé pour
une raison précise comment savez vous
que lui et m'a dit on ne sait pas mais
nous pensons que le suicide du grand
père de peter fait partie du catalyseur
qui a rentré d peter ici dans un premier
temps d'accord ce serait beaucoup plus
facile si peter était au courant c'est
impossible
faites moi confiance il ne doit rien
savoir
eh ben je sais pas comment va réussir à
lui faire faire quoi que ce soit il est
complètement chamboulé
vous devez le convaincre écoutez elle
doit finir cette miss il n'y a pas un
jour dans sa vie où il m'a écouté
pourquoi voulez-vous que commence
maintenant ça serait bien qu'il commence
aujourd'hui d'accord
mais vous feriez mieux d'avoir raison
j'ai raison
[Musique]
bon alors voilà
je sais pas pour vous deux mais nous on
n'a pas l'intention de pourrir au fond
de l'eau dans ce vieux rafiot il y a
quelque chose qui nous a échappé
alors on va se creuser les méninges une
fois de plus et trouver une réponse
compris carmine vous êtes libre
et
écoute moi ce à quoi la caisse claire
apparemment le 'lion' fish a été attaqué
par sa force armée ah oui je crois qu'en
s'est déjà occupé de ça ils croyaient
que c'était le sous marin allemand sur
lequel il tirait donc ils croient que
nous sommes allouées et ils n'arrêteront
pas les torpilles tant qu'on sera pas
mort oui ben on peut pas les contacter
par radio je sais pas et leur dire qu'on
est américaine et ce serait génial mais
les radios fonctionnent pas à cette
profondeur nostra on peut encore
communiqué et comment
un vieux truc de sous mariniers qui
consistait à tirer à blanc depuis les
tubes lance-torpilles chargé de tout et
de n'importe quoi huile débris déchets
uniformes gilets de sauvetage tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient tromper l'ennemi en
surface en lui faisant croire qu'ils
étaient morts mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on
va faire
ah non
nous ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'ils sachent qu'on est vivant et
on veut aussi qu'ils sachent qu'on est
américain et comment on va s'y prendre
on
[Musique]
c'est la der du goût
la drapeau voyons voir ça va ça c'est
bon on peut le mettre dedans et
tablettes non peter ça on va le mettre à
lutter ouais les tablettes
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont les tablettes
mettez les dans la casse c'est bien là
toute mes recherches latence heure de
questions peter jouer je crois qu'ils
devraient l'écouter on a mis assez tu
peux faire mais ce n'était pas une
suggestion
vous rigolez ou quoi qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'ils fassent des tablettes on
peut pas envoyer de la technologie dans
le passé nice ne t'emballe pas je ne
vais pas l'aimer ce que vous allez faire
je n'ai pas d'ordre à recevoir de vous
peter il faut que tu l'aies coûte
vraiment mettez vos tablettes dans la
caisse s'est compris je crois pas mes
amis qu'est ce que vous faites
mettez-vous à ma caisse garmin qu'est ce
que vous faites
mettez vos tablettes dans la caisse 6h
quoi je crois qu'il faut que tu le
fasses confiance sur ce coup-là faire
confiance un type qui pointe une arme
sur moi
montrez lui la lettre il faut qu'ils
sachent qu est ce que je dois savoir on
peut m'expliquer ce qui se passe à la
fin
garmin montrer lu la lettre
c'est la lettre que ton grand-père lycée
cher monsieur williams notre situation
c'est du pays devient désespérée et je
dois prendre mes repères
je ne sais quelles circonstances vous
ont conduit à nous aider mais les
événements de ces dernières 24 heures
m'ont donné des raisons de croire une
victoire une victoire entachée de
sacrifices mais victoire tout de même
vos actes héroïques à bord de ce navire
m'ont prouvé que les évènements devaient
s'enchaînèrent acier et maintenant c'est
à mon tour de gier
je ne peut renoncer à mon devoir ou
cesser de servir je ne commets pas cet
acte par égoïsme
mais en pleine conscience de ses
conséquences ma place et mon
commandement sont avec le lan et wifi je
ne peux le laisser sombrer et ignorer la
détresse de ces milliers d'hommes qui
ont donné leur vie pour leur part dames
et leur pays
par cet acte je remets mon avis entre
vos mains
ainsi que le sort de votre équipage et
de votre pays le mec mes respectueuses
salutations
tony sterling
d'accord
quel mal acquis
le premier bouton mari parfait
et c'est parti feu garmin qu'est ce qui
se passe par des valses et d'air
comprimé c'est pas vrai mais est ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut générer
plus d'air comprimé
bah ouais ouais ça ferait son conseil
central à il va bien fava
paris six gars me passer devant avec
l'élan va derrière
allez on vous émettez d'epinal et stacy
emma ah oui
après fallait continuer continuer à
réduire sa dette
c'est à dire que suis désolé que les
veut dire tu désolé genève va s'en
sortir
regardes tu avanceras les il nous faut
plus de puissance électrique
on n'a pas assez pour lancer notre
pression
attention
chien
qu'est ce que ça donne y avait pas assez
de puissance pour animer les voyants
on est foutu cette fois elle
je peux à réparer un ouais je peux je
peux le réparer regardez les les
batteries sont câblés en séries pour une
puissance maximale nous on doit
seulement faire tourner le compresseur
pas le bateau le navire il faut
seulement monter le câblage des
batteries en parler comme ça on aura
assez de puissance pour lancer le
compresseur c'est assez simple et c'est
possible ouais ouais
saleh pas qu'est ce que vous attendez la
médaille d'honneur du congrès au travail
je me charge du compresseur sais si tu
me suis pour qu'on aille dans le
compartiment de patrie
ces six te plaît et clairement pas si la
sur la gauche et non autre côté
c'est bon alors il ya une boîte à outils
naba demande clé tu veux dépêche
tiens
attention
bastien caroline qui a toujours du
courant dans ce système électrique
il faut qu'ils coupent le circuit
principal coppens et riverains c'est pas
bon j'ai pas
essayez pour voir c'est bon c'est bon
vas-y ça y est c'est fait
dans cet essai t bag leader nantais
bougez pas je peux plus bouger mon je
m'occupe de stacy je reviens de voir
c'est ce qui me reste à faire
garmin garder teuf et panache
professeurs je suis là vous êtes prêts
oui prenez sombre a encore relevé c'est
bon je vais rentrer le chien je tiens
vous la tenez
oui je la tiens je la tiens ça bah ouais
ça
occupez vous donner un exemple si tu vas
bien vrai t'as fait immatriculer ta
voiture de rien non ça d'accord
dans ce cas je venais voir mike d'accord
d'accord ok jazz mc ça va
tu la montée est-ce que ça va je suis
pas au mieux
tu vois ce petit séjour en mer était pas
prévu que la vie est une aventure tu
sais
peter
je sais ce qu'il me reste à faire
non on ne fait pas ça mike keenan
[Musique]
non
ouais ouais bike
m
mais ce tabou dit qu'est ce que tu as
fait
tu as réussi depuis
merci
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya avec
il y mar
toi ça va tu vas bien ça va ça va vas-y
vas-y vas-y
[Musique]
m
qu'est ce que tu veux au nom de dieu des
terres drapeau américain
ces pauvres hères cette fois c'est fait
mais que fait peser sur elle de premier
league à la cgt il ya des survivants du
vol
laquelle des deux personnes pacsées ou
vivant pour l'instant
merci
[Musique]
quoi
on a claqué trois fois les talons
dorothy mais on est parent trocante
je dois je ne saisis pas qu'est ce qu'il
ya je sais pas vous ne savez pas je ne
sais pas il aurait dû ce pas alors
j'aurai à quoi j'ai raté un truc il ya
eu un problème on devrait déjà être
reparti on envoie pu être là ça veut
dire que vous
vous que vous ne savez pas ce qui se
passe ça veut dire que c'est fini on est
mort chut ça va aller ouais
monsieur garmin
il
[Musique]
toute cette opération est classé secret
défense
vous ne devrait jamais parler à qui que
ce soit de tout ça est-ce que c'est
clair alors c'est pour ça que toutes les
informations étaient classées secrètes
et que le navire était sous scellés bien
sûr nous n'irons que tout ceci est
arrivé
wieters a fait plus de soixante dix ans
qu'on savait vous allez venir des
millions de vies dépendent et vous vous
n'avez pas seulement sauver un carquois
vous êtes un homme intelligent
réfléchissez à tous 5 minutes votre
ordinateur a été envoyé au laboratoire
pour analyse et non seulement ces
composants internes mais aussi vos
années d' archives documentaires sur la
guerre mais le lendemain quand ils ont
repêché la fameuse caisse qui contenait
votre tablette est votre ordinateur
ouais c'était à des années lumières de
ce qu'ils auraient pu imaginer en 1933
nous avons pu introduire des normes
avancées technologiques vont rechercher
votre documentation nous ont fait gagner
la seconde guerre mondiale
mais le lay fischer pourquoi le dossier
de votre grand père sera réajusté il a
donné sa vie pour ce pays et pour vous
[Musique]
c'est pour votre grand père je ne sais
pas quoi dire
eh ben je crois que tu avais raison
ton grand père était exceptionnel vous
voulez peut-être qu'à récupérer ma
tablette voire
m
gardez là je crois que je n'aurais pu
bien j'étais sûr que vous disiez ça
ces vieilles histoires demain ne meurt
jamais
ouais
ne vous inquiétez pas il y a plusieurs
postes haut placés qui vous attendent
dans une unité d'élite au centre de
recherche du ministère de la défense
avec un budget tout à fait confortable
d'accord et si je veux juste raconter
l'histoire de mon grand père certes leur
offre en plus personne ne veut croire
votre histoire
m
[Musique]